first ring break I'm pretty much just
gonna go back home kind of skate a
little bit you get to see my Chihuahua's
again I will be on a trip in off of Key
West in Florida on a research cruise for
a oceanography class I'm headed to
Colorado to play some lacrosse games
with a mighty lacrosse and then going to
Spain for like a week I'm gonna be
running through stuff on campus it's
been great
that's okay we have a great time on the
show I'm gonna go to Connecticut to go
see my girlfriend's parents which is
exciting but also a little nerve-racking
I'm going to go to London with 15 of my
best friends I am a member of the
logarithms my whole acapella group is
going on spring tour so I'm in TPP
technology and public programs every
year they organized this trip to DC and
the world enemies like some policymakers
down there I will be sitting out by the
pool as much as possible and trying to
get a tan it's not gonna happen but I
will make the attempt I am going home
tomorrow which is really exciting I
didn't see my parents um in a while so
it's nice to you know get a break from
the school or you can go back in thing
out with them
[Music]
you